[Applause]
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
seen here talking to troops in the front
line town of bakmut on Tuesday hadn't
officially left his embattled country
since Russia's Invasion nearly 10 months
ago
and his visit to the U.S Ukraine's Chief
backer throughout the war comes at a
critical time
Russia continues to Target energy
infrastructure causing millions of
people to endure rolling blackouts and
freezing winter temperatures
Ukrainian military officials points to
the ongoing joint Russia Belarus
military exercises as evidence that
Moscow is preparing for a winter
offensive possibly targeting Kiev the
U.S is expected to announce another two
billion dollars worth of assistance and
a bill currently before Congress would
give Ukraine an additional 40 billion
dollars for 2023. there's also
speculation it may Supply Ukraine with
the highly sophisticated Patriot missile
air defense system despite concerns
among some U.S officials the supplying
Patriots may push Moscow to escalate I
think he's less concerned about Congress
than we were you know three three months
ago it looks like Congress is going to
continue the same policies toward
Ukraine on on weapons in particular
Republicans are solid where Republicans
are not solid and where I'm worried is
budget support and this is the category
of money it's billions of dollars that
taxpayers are giving to make sure that
the Ukrainian state stays afloat and
that is controversial among Republicans
the White House says zielinski's visit
underscores the United States commitment
to supporting Ukraine for as long as it
takes President zielinski says the
monthly costs for defending his country
is around five billion dollars but
standing side by side with President
Biden in Washington and the expected
announcement of billions of dollars more
in Aid will be a very powerful signal to
Vladimir Putin indeed Charles Stratford
Al Jazeera Kiev